hallo herzlich willkommen in meine taten
will heute ist teil eines herbst
specials und ich zeige euch heute wie
man eine kürbis lauch gemacht ich habe
mir dieses rezept ausgesucht weil ich
erstens kürbis der liebe und zweitens
habe ich noch nie gemacht dass ich es
meinen ersten versuch und habe ich mich
im internet durch parasiten durchgelesen
habe jetzt irgendwie was
zusammengeschlossen und mach das jetzt
heute zum zweiten mal
ich war früher nie so der key spenden
weil ich mal ein kind gegessen habt die
wahl mit sahne und mit sehr viel käse
und mir war das alles fehlt so mächtig
also viel zu schwer und ich habe es
jetzt in so eine leichtere variante
verwandelt hatte als viel gemüse mit
drin und statt sahne nehme ich eben qual
das schmeckt dann eben etwas leichter
als seine jetzt eigentlich erstmal die
zutaten für den mürbeteig und seid ihr
euch dann wie es weitergeht
für den teig braucht ihr 250 gramm mehl
130 gramm butter 1 ei und ein paar
gewürze ich habe es hier etwa einen
halben teelöffel salz etwas
paprikapulver bei mir was eskalieren
pulver etwas pfeffer und etwas geriebene
muskatnuss die butter und das eisen kalt
weil es ein mehrbetrag ist und die
schnellste methode für mich möglich
herzustellen ist die im thermomix
deswegen gebe ich da jetzt einfach alle
zutaten rein und lass das auf stufe vier
etwa 40 sekunden vermischen
und so sieht das ganze dann bei mir aus
wenn es verrührt ist richtig schön kalt
und da wird jetzt in der springform
ausgelegt meine springform hat einen
durchmesser von 26 zentimetern aber ihr
könnt auch gerne größere nehmen
die habe ich jetzt schon mit butter ein
gelb insel und mit milden stolz meint
eick nach mir auf meine arbeitsfläche
und formen einfach jetzt ganz schnell zu
einer kugel zusammen
nehme ich mir immer ein kleines
teilstück und formen das zu einer rolle
ich möchte mich jetzt zuerst den rand
auskleiden mit gleichem zweites dann
kann ich das ein bisschen portionen
reichen
und dann legen sie es hier einfach an
den rand und dann drücke ich das einfach
den rand hoch
und den rest für mich einfach zu nah
kugel drückt sie etwas glatt und drückt
es hier am boden fest und sieht das
ganze etwas so aus ich habe jetzt ihr am
rande noch mit so einem teig gretchen
den rand weggeschnitten dass da ein
bisschen gleichmäßiger ist und hab den
übrigen teil einfach mit rein gedrückt
und während ich jetzt die füllung
vorbereite gebe ich das in den
kühlschrank und zeigt euch gleich die
zutaten für die füllung
das sind jetzt die zutaten für die
füllung
ich benutze zwei stangen lauch und davon
eigentlich nur das weiße ich benutze
einen kürbis dass ich jetzt in butternut
das letzte mal habe ich einen computer
benutzt den hokkaido könnt ihr mit
schale verwenden den button hat müsst
ihr schienen und star braucht ihr etwa
350 bis 400 gramm
dann nehme ich 250 gramm quark und 50
milliliter mädels ihr könnt aber auch
sahne benutzen aber ich finde mit quark
schmeckt etwas leichter ihr braucht drei
eier und natürlich käse ich habe jetzt
hier in einem gatter und brauchte etwas
zu 100 gramm
und jetzt kommen die gewürze das ist
jetzt ein vorschlag von mir die müsst
ihr nicht so verwenden wenn ihr nicht
wollt
und zwar habe ich hier so ein kleines
stück ingwer was ich verwende
und hier habe ich einen teelöffel
thymian pfeffer und salz salz habe ich
etwa einen halben teelöffel dann ein
viertel teelöffel currypulver und väter
teelöffel cayennepfeffer etwas
muskatnuss frisch geriebene hier habe
ich etwas kreuzkümmel gemahnen
und hier noch eine prise zimt und die
prise zimt die macht wirklich das ganze
gericht aus als sie die miester wirklich
mit verwenden kannst eine ganz kleine
prise das macht wirklich einen ganz
tollen geschmack
jetzt nehme ich mir zuerst den lauch und
schneit den 1
in feine ringe und dann gebe ich das
einfach in sollen falls sei er mit rein
und weiter das jetzt einmal kurz unter
kaltem wasser abwaschen damit an keine
sandkörner hier mit drin bleiben
dann kümmere mich nicht um den kürbis
sich nehmen da jetzt einfach mal die
hälfte
da ich jetzt nur 350 g
und wie gesagt müsst ihr den button hat
auf jeden fall scheinen weil die schale
nämlich nicht wie der kürbis muss jetzt
noch fein gewürfelt werden
ich schneide jetzt erst mal entscheiden
und dann die scheiben in kleine streifen
und dann eben im körper
so sieht der kürbis jetzt aus und da
muss jetzt ganz kurz blanchiert werden
da habe ich hier jetzt bereits wasser
zum kochen gebracht und gibt da mein
kürbisfleisch mit dazu einfach damit so
ein bisschen weich wird eine minute
später gebe ich dann einfach noch den
lauf mit dazu
damit er auch einfach so ein bisschen
blockiert wird da verliert er auch so
ein bisschen von seiner schärfe und es
lasse ich so etwa 23 minuten da drin und
nehmens dann gleich mit raus danach
nehmt ihr euch dann einfach das gemüse
raus und gibt es auf den vorbereiteten
teig dann verteidigt es hier einfach
schön fokus nehme ich jetzt einfach
wieder den thermomix dann habe ich es
auch nicht ausgewaschen braucht man hier
auch nicht
hier gebe ich jetzt den quark rein dann
kommen dann auf die eier mit rein dann
die milch unsere kräuter
und ich schreibe jetzt hier noch den
internet rein und dann wird das ganze
ganz einfach auf stufe 5 und verrührt
bis es dann eben so aussieht
unternehmt ihr euch einfach den guss und
steht den über das gemüse drüber und
dann sieht es hier einmal schön verteilt
und jetzt kommt hier noch der käse
obendrauf den habe ich jetzt schon
gegeben
einfach 100 gramm gouda ich kann das
auch machen
und dann wird der auch riesch bei 180
grad etwa 35 bis 45 minuten bei ober und
unterhitze gebacken
meine kiss habe ich jetzt aus dem ofen
rausgenommen last jetzt so etwa 56
minuten abkühlen
und wenn sie dann vom spring vom rand
lösen dann rennt kann ich einfach so
auflösung und ich las die quiche teils
einfach drauf und transportiert sie so
die spö nämlich es gerade noch ein
bisschen zu warm zum schneiden versuchen
und so sieht sie dann von ihnen aus
die kiste könnt ihr kalt oder warm essen
mir schmeckt sie ganz gut warm ich hab
selber auch schon am nächsten tag hat
gegessen schmeckt genauso gut ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
ich hoffe dass euch dieses rezept
gefällt und das erst mal ausprobieren
werdet wie gesagt könnt ihr ja viele
sachen hier verändern also den kürbis
ersetzen oder eben die gewürze oder dem
käse
das ist wie praktisch schon grundrezept
wieder und dann sehen wir morgen schon
wieder
also wünsche euch noch einen ganz
schönen tag und bis dann tschüss
mehr